[Music]
las vegas city council's proposal to
impose a curfew for those under 21 has
now hit a roadblock yes it has now
here's where the boundaries where that
curfew would have applied in the
downtown area between ogden 8th carson
and maine jeremy j ford is live with why
the aclu came out against the plan
that's right the aclu is calling the
proposed curfew to keep people out of
this area of fremont absolutely
unconstitutional the proposal would
create a nightly curfew from 9 p.m at
night to 5 a.m that is in the morning if
you're under the age of 21. the city of
las vegas was supposed to vote on that
today but it was postponed once the aclu
weighed in
the item
well 33
wrong
has been stricken the aclu of nevada
attended the city council meeting to
oppose the fremont curfew because they
say it's an unconstitutional proposal
aclu executive director athar hasabula
tells me on monday he met with the city
council's recommending committee with a
very special request show us the data
that suggests that those between 18 and
21
pose a heightened safety risk causing
the proposal to be pulled from the
docket it's pretty ridiculous we often
see dumb proposals and we see separately
dangerous proposals but it's rare that
we get the combination of both dumb and
dangerous proposals built into one and
this is one of them so i went down to
fremont and spoke with taurus trayley
hines who has a teenage daughter and
believes the idea of a curfew is a good
one it prevents kids from getting in
trouble and also it just protects them
overall she says there's other
alternatives for underage adults after
dark this with drinking gambling i just
feel that they're just too young i just
don't think it's right for them to be
here to do that
now i reached out to the city of las
vegas for a response and what's next i'm
told with new security measures taken at
the fremont street experience along with
more police presence and city marshals
have had a positive impact on the area
reporting from las vegas jeremy j ford
is live
local now